israel has carried out the third day of
air raids on the gaza strip
missiles struck refugee camps and
destroyed apartment buildings
eyewitnesses say the attacks took place
without warning
we were praying suddenly we found a
missile in our home we didn't know where
it hit us from it was so sudden
israel says the target was
palestinian-islamic jihad and the two of
the armed groups leaders have been
killed
khalid mansour a senior member of
al-qud's brigade the group's military
wing was killed in rafa near the
egyptian border
israel also says tunnels outposts rocket
launch sites and weapons stores have
been destroyed islamic jihad responded
by firing rockets towards israel
some of which were shot down by the iron
dome missile defense system other
smaller palestinian groups are also
believed to have fired rockets
several countries and organizations have
condemned the violence the u.n
humanitarian coordinator for gaza says
she's gravely concerned by the civilian
deaths and injuries while another u.n
official says the israeli attacks are
not just illegal but irresponsible and
that gaza is on the verge of a
humanitarian crisis
with border crossings still closed no
humanitarian or medical aid is able to
enter gaza a fuel shortage has already
forced the sole power plant to shut down
and hospitals are warning of dire
consequences if assistance does not
arrive soon
yumnicide al jazeera gaza city
in gaza have been sharing their
experiences on social media one mother
iman bashir posted a video online of her
small son while the bombardment was
underway
[Music]
earlier she told al jazeera about the
impact the fighting is having on her
family
it's overwhelming actually most of the
time
um
we're trying our best actually for the
first time we had uh we brought them
coloring for their faces so that so that
we would try to distract them because we
know that once they ask questions we
don't have answers or
or we can answer them but we know in
their eyes that
they know that we are liars i've been
telling them that it is fireworks i've
been telling them that people are happy
that um that because
there have been an um a
high school graduation um a few days ago
so it's kind of similar but
the the sounds are louder
so
after a while i started feeling that
they don't believe me but they don't
want to say it
um
but this is new to me because now i have
a baby girl
this is different from the last word
because this girl is six months old this
is her first aggression
and i don't have my husband my husband
is doing an m.a in
in wyoming
and one in wyoming university so i i'm
all here by my own and i i know that my
situation is nothing compared to other
mothers
who has waking up finding
they are homeless finding that their
their their children are buried under
adorable
uh who has who have lost many children
i don't think that my kids have even
recovered from the last war
and to tell you the truth at some point
i started to feel that
my kids and the girls and children are
some kind of an entertainment material
for the world
i mean i was trending the last war and
i'm trending this war so but
what then in case israel decides to
to plan a war and to launch a
a war
like
america supports it and
nobody stops them from from doing this
herbal
acts and from
terrorizing our children
alhassan zomlos is the palestinian
ambassador to the united kingdom he
demands israel immediately stops its
aggression
so i'm not sure if ceasefire is the
right term ending the israeli assault
aggression is the right term and there
has been a lot of efforts uh with
egypt and with regional powers and of
course with international powers
to end this unprovoked
assault this very murderous machine
and the security council is supposed to
meet tomorrow upon the request of the
state of palestine and the support of
key security council members and the
arab members of the of the council and
the u.n
so we have no confirmation yet except
that the bombardment continues the
targeting of civilians continues the
israeli trading of our blood blood the
palestinian blood this is just their
part of starting their election campaign
early on on gaza as as happens all the
time
politicians in israel compete who has
more palestinian blood on their
on their hands and therefore this is an
opportunity for for all of us the
palestinian people to actually unite
because this is not an issue with gaza
only this is an issue with the
palestinian people you have reported
what happened today in jerusalem the
storming of al-aqsa mosque the thousands
of israeli illegal settlers in our most
sacred sites the occupied city of
jerusalem this is an
all-out aggression by israel assault by
israel on us everywhere wherever we are
whether in the west bank whether in
jerusalem in gaza or even refugees
outside